homage to the buddha the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one so uh this evening we were going to look at the kalama discourse the uh the one that concerns the buddha's visit to kesaputta
it looks like this was his first visit because when he gets there the kalamas are all confused and they're bewildered because teachers say that then they've got the answer and everybody else happy right it's the usual thing of i'm right and everybody else is wrong there are some monks and brahmins venerable sir who visit kesa puta
they expound and explain their own doctrine the doctrines of others they despise revile and pull to pieces uh venerable sir there is doubt there is uncertain uncertainty in us concerning them which of these venerable monks and brahmins spoke the truth on which falsehood now
We don't really realize what the problem is until we get towards the end of the discourse.
So to make this more plain to us about what it is that they're concerned with is the fact that they are worried about karma and rebirth.
So remember in those days, that was a given for the vast majority.
There were materialists who thought you disappeared when you died, but most believed that there was a rebirth
and there was confusion as to what actually uh you know caused you to get a rebirth in one of the realms so you could be born in a violent realm of the angry god or the hungry ghost realm uh now always longing but never satisfied you could be born as a dull-minded animal a chattel it's on somebody's farm you could of course you could end up being a denizen of hell uh which is a constant pain and suffering
just as an aside this uh sort of existential fear by the greeks was um that they had fate by which they meant that these gods that they believed in were were just you know doing whatever they wanted to do no matter what happened to human beings um so they would they would lose their sort of personal agency in this chaotic world
you know earthquakes going up big storms and so on and so forth in the medieval period the horror was of course to go to hell and the catholic church softened it by creating a purgatory so that only those who were really really naughty ended up in eternal hell and the rest could go to purgatory for a while be cleansed and then shoot off to heaven um and of course today because if you are a
um annihilist if you're a a a scientific materialist um you're looking into nothingness and this is explored especially by the philosopher nietzsche and then heidegger and some of you might know and what nietzsche talked about was the the abyss um he uh he obviously came close to what it means to become nothing at all to die finish you know
which is the death of self.
There's another very famous philosopher called Nishitani, who had studied with people like Heidegger, and then went through his Zen practice, realized that this abyss was actually the loss of the self.
And that once you leaped over that, you found what we would call an advance.
Okay, so back to the Kalamas.
now he doesn't fall the buddha doesn't fall into the edit trying to convince them this is the point he rather he tries to give them ways and means in which they can find out for themselves whether something is true or not so he leads them he leaves them uh he gives them a method you know that they can find a way out of their doubt out of their confusion
First of all, he tells them what they should not do, then what they should do, and finally how to develop further qualities that would lead to a happy realm and a happy life here and now.
So this is where he makes this very famous statement, which is often understood to be a declaration of believe what you want, freedom of belief, but it's not.
It's a freedom to investigate, a freedom to question, right?
It is proper for you, Kalamas, to doubt, to be uncertain.
Uncertainty has arisen in you about what is doubtful.
Come, Kalamas, do not go upon what has been acquired by repeated hearing.
I mean, consider how Trump lies and lies and lies and then somebody actually believes him.
Nor upon tradition, nor upon rumour.
nor, like rumour would be, you know, social media, stuff coming through social media, nor upon a scripture, nor upon surmise, you know, just an opinion, a guess, but you don't have the proper evidence.
And that means that, you know, sometimes you don't have to come to a conclusion, nor upon an axiom.
I mean, just because something is universally accepted doesn't mean it's true.
nor upon specious reasoning, clever, clever, clever reasoning, that confuses you, nor upon a bias towards a notion that has been pondered on.
I mean, this is what we get with information silos.
Nor upon another seeming ability, nor upon a consideration, this monk is our teacher, Kalamas.
uh um so in other words even even somebody whom you really really trust whatever they say you still have to question and then you would know for yourselves he said these things are immoral these things are blameable these things are censured by the wives undertaken and observed these things lead to harm and to ill so abandon them
so in other words completely against anything like blind faith so again he's not asking that he's not asking them to dismiss all the teaching he's asking them to be pragmatic to have a hands-on investigation obviously he'd be very much against the post-modern idea that you know every opinion is equally true uh you create your own reality and all that
being selective about what you can and what you can't believe.
And that's as though the spiritual path is some sort of smorgasbord and you can take what you want.
And of course, Western Buddhists often tend to do that.
They'll accept some of what's in the scriptures, but not all of it, such as rebirth.
So now the test for rebirth, and this was generally accepted at the time,
remember there were the james and uh other other sex who understood that there was some connection between your ethical model behavior and where you took rebirth so he asks them come on when you yourselves know these things are bad these things are blameable these things are censured by the why undertaken and observed these things lead to harm and ill abandonment
And of course, he says the opposite for what is good.
And then he continues this sort of Socratic dialogue.
What do you think, Kalama?
Does greed manifest in someone for their benefit or harm?
For their harm, Venerable Sir.
Kalama's being given to greed, being overwhelmed and vanquished mentally by greed,
such person take life steel commits adultery and tells lies and they prompt others to do so likewise will that not eventually be harmful and damaging for them yes bendable sir and of course he says the same for hatred and delusion and then he asks what do you think are these things good or bad
bad venerable sir blameable or not blameable blameable venerable sir censured or praised by the wise censured venerable sir undertaken and observed do these things lead to harm and ill or not how does it strike you undertaken and observed these things lead to harm and ill that's clear to us and of course the same is true for what is beneficial uh the opposite of course
and he simply uses the uh the negative to point to what is positive what do you think kalamas does absence of greed manifest in someone for their benefit or harm for their benefit venerable sir and so he goes on through hatred and delusion so then uh having got them to that stage
uh he then opens up to a practice of meta um the disciples of the noble ones kalamas who in this way in this way is a devoid of coveting devoid of ill will undiluted clearly comprehending and mindful dwells pervading one quarter with the thought of love
likewise the second likewise the third likewise the fourth so above and below and across he dwells encompassing all sentient beings everywhere in the entire cosmos with the abundant exalted boundless thought of love that is free of hatred and malice so and then of course he said the same for compassion joy and equanimity or peacefulness so here
um he's now given them a way in which they can develop a good heart so that upon death they can they can presume to be born into a happy realm so their fundamental problem is of course is karma and rebirth and um here he gives them rather i think really quite cleverly
for consolations or assurances and he covers every angle suppose there is a hereafter and there is a fruit result of deeds done well or ill then it is possible that at the dissolution of the body after death i shall arise in a heavenly world which is possessed of the state of bliss so
right so if that if if karma is correct and whether it is fruit then upon death you know i'll end up in in a in a heavenly realm um this he says is your first consolation your first assurance supposing there is no hereafter and there's no fruit no result of deeds done well or ill yet in this world
here and now free from hatred free from malice safe and sound and happy i keep myself so you will find this to be your second consolation and assurance so even if there isn't any rebirth it's good to do it anyway now suppose evil results before an evil doer i however don't think of doing harm to anyone
then how can ill affect me who has no done no harm or any harmful deed you will find this to be your third consolation assurance so even if there isn't a consequence to evil doing at least in your own heart you're in a good state you're in a beautiful mental state and finally supposing evil deeds
uh do not excuse me the first was if there was result then you'll be free of that that's your consolation the last one is suppose evil results do not be for an evil doer then i see myself purified in any case you will find this to be your fourth consolation and assurance
So what's the teaching?
Well, the basic line is the inner happiness of moral integrity surpasses that momentary superficial pleasures gained through delusion, hatred, and ill will.
So his approach, you can see, I mean, this really shows us how, what a skillful teacher the Buddha was.
these people are not ready for the eightfold path and the four noble truths uh they've come to him uh well they they they've told him about their confusion and the last thing they want is for somebody to come along and say no no that's all rubbish listen to me i know the truth so he gives them this way of investigating themselves and this this this uh inspires them so much
that they take refuge in the Buddha.
So one can presume that either later in the day, after he's taken a meal, because that's when he would normally arrive on your arm drowned in the morning, after the meal and he'd been refreshed and he's had a rest, he would then talk about the Four Noble Truths and the Eightfold Path, now that he's got their confidence.
so you can see that the um uh the structure of the just as an aside the structure of this discourse you know how it from confusion through investigation ethical discernment there's an inner transformation this brings about confidence and ultimately when the buddha tells them about the four noble truths and so on and of course the basana they will reach they will have realized the truth
so i hope my words have been of some assistance they have not caused any confusion and that by your commitment to your practice and uh careful questioning of anything you you hear you will be liberated from all suffering tuna rather than later